what do you
make of the news maybe you can update it
in terms of life being discovered
in the atmosphere of venus is that sorry
okay you have a opinion i can already
tell you have opinions
was that fake news i got excited i saw
that what's the
what's the final uh is there a life on
venus
so the detection that was reported was
the detection of the molecule phosphine
um and they said
that they tried every other mechanism
they could think of to produce phosphine
and they none of no mechanism worked
and then they said well we know that
life produces phosphine and so that was
sort of the
the train of logic and um
i don't personally believe that
phosphate was detected in the first
place
okay so i mean this is just one study
but i
as a layman i'm skeptical
a little bit about tools that
sense the contents of an atmosphere like
contents of an atmosphere from remotely
and making conclusive statements about
life
oh yeah well that connection that you
just made the contents of the atmosphere
to the life
yeah is is a tricky one and
yeah i know that that claim received a
lot of criticism for
the lines of logic that went from
detection to
uh to claim of life even the detection
itself though
did doesn't doesn't meet the sort of
historical
scientific standards of a detection
the it was a very tenuous detection and
only one line of the species was
detected
and a lot of really complicated data
analysis methods had to be applied to
even make that
weak detection yeah um so it could be it
could be noise it could be polluted data
it could be all
those things and so it doesn't have it
doesn't meet the
the level of uh rigor that you would
hope but of course
i mean we're doing our best and it's
clear that uh
the human species are hopeful to find
life
clearly yes everyone is so excited about
that possibility
you